ججد هنا وسط مدينه تل ابيب حيث يحتاج الاف
الاسرائيليين على سياسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو في
اداره الحرب على غزه ويطالبون باقاله
الحكومه والتوجه بشكل فوري الى
انتخابات مبكره ويحملون نتنياهو مسؤوليه
الحاصل في السابع من اكتوبر وايضا يحملونه
مصير حياه الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين
في غزه نستطيع ان نرى ان هنالك لافتات
تدين نتنياهو وتصفه بالمذنب ويقولون بانه
حان الوقت لاقاله بنيامين نتنياهو وتحميل
هذه المسؤوليه مسؤولي الفشل الاستخباراتي
هذه المظاهره ليست المظاهره الاولى
والوحيده التي يشهدها الشارع الاسرائيلي
نتحدث عن تنظيم مظاهرات في اماكن متفرقه
في اسرائيل في حيفا في مدينه تل ابيب وحتى
في قسار نتحدث عن مظاهرات ايضا كانت في
محيط بيت رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيل بمين
نتنياهو كل هذه الحراكات الاحتجاجيه تاتي
كمحاوله للضغط على صناع القرار في اسرائيل
وايضا على الحكومه الاسرائيليه بوقف الحرب
على غزه اقاله الحكومه وذهب الانتخابات
الثوريه وايضا ابرام صفقه لاطلاق صلاح
الاسر الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه من
مدينه تل ابيب فاطمه خميسي
الجزيره